Music. Welcome to the DDPS seminar. Everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have a sense, unmute yourself and
ask questions, or we can wait until the end
to the Q and A sessions. Second, today's
GDPs seminar is open to external audience,
therefore no classified discussion
is allowed. So watch out. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel. That's about it now,
let me briefly introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host Qing Yao Lai,
who is an assistant professor in the Department of
geophysics and affiliated faculty of the Institute
for computational and mathematical engineering so
called ICME at Stanford. Before joining Stanford,
she was an assistant professor at Princeton
University. She received an undergraduate degree,
2013 in physics from National Taiwan University
and a PhD in mechanical and aerospace engineering
from Princeton University. She completed her
postdoctoral research in geophysics at Lamont
Earth Observatory at Columbia University,
where she received the Lamont postdoctoral
fellowship. Our current research focuses
on enhancing the representation of machine
learning models to tackle multi scale problems.
She was the recipient of the 2023 Google Research
Scholar Award and 2024 Sloan research fellowship.
Today, Yao will talk about machine precision,
neural networks for multi scale dynamics. I'm sure
we are going to hear a wonderful talk from her.
But before I pass the button to Yao as a tradition
to the DDPS seminar, let me ask a question,
in somewhat informal questions to her, to
get to know her, about someone outside of
her technical reasons, all right, so I happen to
know that you like to travel, if you can share
the most favorite places you have visited
so far, and share with us why you think so.
Yeah, first of all, thank you. Yong Soo for
the warm introduction and invitation. I was
not expecting a question, I guess the travel.
I really, really enjoy my travel in Europe in
particular, just because I learned
about it in history in my childhood,
and it was just wonderful to see historical
buildings. You also just distract myself from
the daily routine. So that's the part I really
enjoy. I don't know if this is sufficient. Awesome
also, yeah, there's no correct answer here.
Thank you so much for sharing your experience,
traveling, experience, all
right, the stage is yours?
Okay? Yeah, so, yeah, I'm excited to give the
talk today, and today I'll talk about the work
in my group. My group has been developing recently
to enhance the representation accuracy of neural
networks. I hope I can convince you that it is,
it is kind of problematic that vanilla neural
networks suffer to represent multi scale data,
which motivate us to develop machine precision
neural networks. And this work that will discuss
today was also published in journal computational
physics and physical review letters next slide.
All right, so there has been an emerging trend of
research using machine learning models to emulate
numerical simulations to substantially reduce its
computational cost. And success stories include
the recent bloom of machine learning based weather
forecast models. A classical numerical weather
forecast prediction is made by numerically solving
coupled partial deputy equations that describe the
evolution of states, and that's denoted by z here
and in the ML emulator, a physics free machine
learning model is used to approximate the dynamics
that is denoted by f here, which describe the time
derivative of the state. So the machine learning
model will take the states at the previous time
as input and then predict the state at the next
time as output. This approach is very successful,
and after training with the year five weather,
we announced. This data deep mine has shown that
they're able to use the graph new network to take
the states in the current time step and predict
the next time step, and then take the next time
step result to predict the next next time step
and so on. So they show that this can make 10 day
weather forecast with precision that is comparable
to the state of the art freeze, space, numerous
numerical weather prediction model, and this
takes a lot of time to train, but when once it
is trained, it takes negligible amount of time to
make predictions. So this is just another example,
an image of the neural network represented global
wing field from one of the recent machine learning
weather forecast model. And here, if you compare
with the ground truth training data from numerical
weather prediction, now you can see that the
machine learning based weather forecast can well
capture the large scale feature, right? So these
two wing fields are almost indistinguishable,
but the ML based model is missing a lot of the
fine scale, high frequency details that's present
in the numerical data, and even more evident
in this plot. So here the is the spectrum of
the wing field. The horizontal axis is the wave
number, the vertical axis is the power density.
The black line is the spectrum from E verify
data, and the colored lines are the spectrum from
various different machine learning based weather
prediction model. So you can see that most of the
ML based model capture the spectrum at low wave
number because they capture a large, large scale
features. However they deviate from the from the
spectrum for higher wave numbers. So it's missing
all the fine scale, high frequency details. And
this is even more severe when you look at the
prediction in at day 10. So at daytime, a lot the
mismatch between the ML based model and the ground
truth happens at even lower wave numbers. Oops,
I think, sorry. Are you still seeing my screen?
No screen is gone
now, sorry, let me reshare again.
I know what happened. Share Screen.
Take your time
window, all right,
yeah, the first page we are seeing. Yeah,
okay, so let me go back to the slide, yeah,
okay, so what I just described is related
to the so called spectral bias of the neural
network. Special bias refer to neural networks
tendency to prioritize fitting functions with a
certain frequency range, as demonstrated in this
2019 paper. I really like this figure. I think
it's really clear. So here, the blue line is the
target function, and the green line, green curve,
is the new network prediction over iterations. So
you can see that the neural network can first fit
the low frequency function, but then it takes a
lot longer to fit the high frequency signals in
the target function. And this is this is bad news,
because problems in the physical sciences often
exhibit multi scale features, and neural networks
are used because of its property as a universal
function, approximator. However, in practice,
neural network often failed to capture fine
scale details due to its spectral bias. So
a popular solution is the so called Fourier
feature, and this was proposed in 10s et al,
2020 paper. This Fourier feature is composed of
basis functions of cosine and sines, and the maps
the input coordinate of the multi layer perceptron
into this feature before passing the information
into the hidden layers of the neural network. And
the intuition is that you can give some hints to
the neural network, that there exists a range of
frequencies that are relevant to represent the
data. So you can see here, this is the original
image represented by the regular neural network.
It looks kind of blurry, just like what we saw
earlier, but after applying the Fourier spec,
the Fourier features, now the new algorithm
capture all the accurate details in the image.
Okay, so that was spectral bias. And now there's
another additional challenge of machine learning
emulators. So this is one of the machine learning
based emulator, forecast net, and it's prediction
out to 30 days, you can see that the error start
to accumulate, and then the temperature field,
just we call it blow up over time. And because
just recall that, in this case, neural network is
used to approach. Approximate the time derivatives
of the states the dynamics. So if the new network
have spectral bias, it could cause errors of
approximating the states at smaller scales,
and this error can be propagated in times, and
therefore make long term prediction terribly
inaccurate. So special bias could be one of the
reason that can cause the blow up behavior we
see in emulators. So to summarize, the big
questions that I want to discuss today is
strategies that can tackle spectral bias of
the neural network. And another question is,
how can we make the neural network approximation
as accurate as possible. So this is today's
outline. I'll first talk about a algorithm our
group develops that can push the error down to
machine precision and tackle the spectral bias.
And I'll talk about the extension for problems
related to PDEs. And this is still preliminary and
ongoing work. And finally, I'll talk about some
challenges and promising promises in this area.
So okay, so expressiveness of neural network.
Now here my postdoc, young, he used a vanilla
neural network to fit a 1d function. So here
he's just a silly analytical function that
we try to fit. And the y axis is the output
neural network output. The X axis is the neural
network input. The blue line is the function we're
trying to fit. The dash red is the neural network
prediction. So here the loss function quantifies
the difference between the ground truth function
and the neural network prediction. And you can see
that with the regular neural network, the error
can go down to 10 to the minus five. But you know,
the question is, why does the error not get
lower when we train for longer iterations? So
here we try increasing the depth of the neural
network, increasing the width, we were always
seeing a saturation of error like this. So the
question is, why can we what's the minimum error?
We can push the error down to, you know, in your
network, if neural network are truly universal
function approximators, it should not have this.
Should not you should have it can correspond to,
it should be able to achieve arbitrary, small
error theoretically. So here we propose the multi
multi stage neural network that use a subsequent
neural network to effectively learn to correct
for the errors from the first neural network. And
this multi stage neural network can achieve much
better precision with less number of total neural
network parameters and less computational cost
compared to a single neural network. I don't know
why this is happening, but let's go back. Okay,
so before going into the detail of the algorithm,
I want to draw your attention to this very simple
explanation of the spectral bias. So here, this
is the expression of a single layer neural network
with input x and output U. Here the W, and these
are the neural network parameters, and here the
loss function quantify the mean square error
between the neural network output and a ground
truth. So here we denote the Fourier transform
of the function as a u hat and the class function
can also be written in as the Fourier transform
of the neural network prediction. So if we will
skip the derivation here, but it can be shown that
the gradient of the so during gradient descent,
we know that the loss function is updated based
on the gradient of the loss function with respect
to the neural network parameters. And can be
shown that the gradient of the loss function
decay exponentially with higher frequencies.
And this is important because it shows that
the gradients become very small for larger
K and therefore it would take extremely long
number of iterations to learn the high frequency
functions. And this is a simple explanation for
the origin of neural networks spectral bias.
So to mitigate this problem, it's important to
rescale the neural network weights. Note that
in this expression, the exponential decay.
In this decay, it is the this factor, the
frequency, divided by w, that determine the decay,
and w is the neural network weight. So if we can
increase the new and equal weights proportionally
with the frequency k that we want to capture. We
can keep this gradient large for larger k, and
this can reactivate the learning of high frequency
functions. So here in our implementation,
we have a scaling factor called cut. And that's a
multiplier in front of the weights of the neural
network that connects the input to the first
hidden layer. And note that this is similar to
the Fourier feature implementation, but here we
we don't include a cosine activation function,
because that's not necessary. So the Kappa is a
user defined parameter. I can set the value. Large
kappa has the effect of rescaling the input x and
make it easier to learn high frequency functions.
So we can see that with large copper, the the
new network predict new network approximation
can fit the target function better. And this
was also shown by this paper by J tech in
2020 in the case when kappa is smaller, is really
struggling to fit the target function. So however,
we are still, even though we increase the Kappa
you're seeing, we're still missing part of the
target function. So here we change the activation
function from high volume tangent to sine, and it
shows that the fitting is much better. Therefore,
a combination of large scaling factor and the
sinusoidal activation function gives much better
error. And we know that this implementation has
a similar training error compared to the Fourier
feature net. So one thing to be careful with is
that the network can start to overfit the data
if you increase the coupon further. So here we
can see that if you just look at the training
loss I when you increase the scaling factor,
you can keep minimizing the loss. So here the
Kappa is like up to 300 the loss looks very
small. However, this is actually quite deceiving,
because if you look at the actual prediction of
the neural network with larger kappa value on
the higher resolution grid point, you're seeing
that it's actually overfitting the function
and have all these Wiggles. So it's important
to know that there's actually a optimal range of
kappa that works well. Here we show the means,
root mean square error of the neural network as a
function of the scaling factor kappa, and you can
see that the optimal kappa is related to the
dominant frequency in a in a target function,
which is denoted by FD, and this is aligned with
our expectation from the spectral bias analysis.
I don't know what happened. Let's keep this is
somehow like skipping skipping many slides. I'll
go back where we are. Okay, here's good.
Yeah, alright. So, so that was for fitting
high frequency functions. Now we have another
issue, independent issue, to overcome. So when
the new network training error is very small, we
know that the learning become very slow, right?
And so here is the main idea of the multi stage
neural network, inspired by perturbation theory.
Here we write the neural network approximated
function as a superposition of the leading order
approximation, u naught and the higher order error
terms like u1 u2 etc. So here, epsilon one is a
small constant, and epsilon is much, much smaller
compared to epsilon one. The U naught, u1 u2 etc,
are the neural networks from different stages. So
although the first neural network you not doesn't
perfectly fit the target function, we can use
a subsequent neural network you want to learn
to correct for the residue from the previous
neural network. And because here the u naught,
u1 u2 are all orders of magnitude one functions,
so it's easy for neural network to capture all
these error terms, instead of having a single
neural network capturing all the small magnitude
details. And note that there, here's a list
of related work with similar strategies, so
sequential residue learning and multi layer neural
networks. This paper actually was, is also able to
get the error down to machine precision. It's also
the stack networks by Howard at all and precision
machine learning. So this is really a, I think,
a rising trend of research to try to understand
what control the error of the neural network
approximation. Okay, so here is a numerical
demonstration. We this is the another 1d target
function we are trying to fit. And so here show,
after one single neural network, the error of the
first neural network. So the magnitude is about
10. To the minus four the x axis is the input of
the neural network. So we do a Fourier transform
of these error and look at it in a frequency
space. So here you can see the dominant frequency
corresponding to the error of this first neural
network. And then we use a second neural network,
a subsequent neural network, to learn to fit
the error from the first neural network. So
now the second neural network with the first one
altogether has an error that's much smaller, so
about 10 to the minus eight. And one thing that's
interesting is if you look at the frequency of
this error of the second new network is actually
much higher. So we can look at the frequency error
in the Fourier space. It corresponds to a higher
dominant frequency. And then we can repeat this
procedure. We use the third neural network to
learn the to approximate error from the second
neural network. And now the residual of the three
networks combined become 10 to the minus 11. And
the same story. You know, after all, the networks
are stacked together, we can achieve the error
that's close to 10 minus minus 13 and the now the
error has a really, really high frequency. So here
is just to show the error of the approximation
throughout iterations. You can see that the
error convergence for this multi staging training
scheme is a lot faster with training iterations
compared to a single neural network. And this is
just shows that throughout different stages, the
error of the approximation gets lower at the same
time the dominant frequency of the error increase.
And this actually, we see that it follows a power
law with exponent one over six. This exponent is
actually quite universal. We see this for various
different target function that we have tried, and
is relatively unchanged with different sampling
data and different layer, different architecture,
different number of layers, number of units.
I'd love to if you have ideas of how to explain
this exponent, I would love to chat more about
it. Okay, so that was for very simple, right?
Like 1d learning 1d function. And here we want to
see if we can use this idea to learn to the data
like the data of flow field. So here my student,
Jenkin, she used the special methods to create the
numerical simulation that solves the this to the
incompressible equation with Reynolds number 2000
and here is the vorticity field that evolved with
with time the and here is the energy spectrum. So,
so we like this example because it has the
energy spectrum that spans over scales with
two orders of magnitude. So it's a simple
example of a mouse field problem. So here,
what we want to do is to just use the amount usage
network to fit a snapshot of these flow field. So
this is the target function of the flow field at
a particular at a time. And the here is the neural
network representation of the data. So the input
of a new network is the coordinate and the output
of a new network is the string function, the flow
field. And you can see that the difference is
quite small. This is the error between the target
function and the neural network approximation.
The magnitude of the error is about 10 to the
minus four. If you look at this error in space,
it's quite interesting. It has these Wiggles. So
we look at this error in Fourier space, and we see
that there's some dominant frequency of the error.
So here is the spectrum, energy spectrum, of the
ground truth data showing black, and the neural
network data showing blue, and you can see the
spectral bias. So the neural network capture the
small wave number energy spectrum, but mismatch
has a mismatch in a high wave number region. Okay,
so we're going to do the same procedure now. We
will use a second neural network to fit the error
from this first neural network, and this is the
error after the second neural network. Now it has
the magnitude of 10 to the minus seven. And the
error of the second neural network now has a
higher dominant wave number. And we keep this
procedure after the third stage, the error can be
down to close to machine precision of the double
floating point 10 to the minus 16, and now has a
you can see that the energy spectrum, the neural
network approximation, correspond to an energy
spectrum as aligned really well with the target
function. So this is just in comparison comparing
the multi stage. Network with the regular network.
We show that in for the energy spectrum, the
here, the red line is the regular neural network,
the green line is the monetization neural network
that can tackle the spectral bias and agrees very
well with the target function. We look at the loss
convergence compared to the regular single neural
network that has a lost loss value that converges
over iterations with the multi stage neural
network, we can achieve unprecedented accuracy and
down to percentage machine precision of the double
precision floating point. Okay, so this is a quick
summary. So for this data fitting problem, the
training data for the highest stage neural network
comes from the error from the previous stage and
the error of the higher stage neural network are
usually higher frequency functions. So although it
is difficult for vanilla neural network to capture
high frequency data, we can use a scaling factor
kappa that can be determined directly using the
dominant frequency of the residues. And this is
exciting for us, because using this multi stage
neural network, we can tackle the spectral bias
and achieve unprecedented accuracy. Okay, is
doing that again? So, yeah, that was, I want to
emphasize that sounds like there's lots of steps,
but actually all of these steps can be automated.
Okay, so,
so far we have talked about machine procedure,
new network for tackling spectral bias, right?
And the next question is, can, can we use this for
PDE problems? Can PD residues also be down, pushed
down to immersion precision? So this is a much,
much harder problem to to investigate, and it's
still ongoing work. In particular, I'll, in the
next few slides, I'll talk about the application
of multi station neural network to physics inform
your networks. So for background information,
physics inform your network. Leverage neural
networks expressiveness to approximate solutions
to PDS, and because neural networks are analytical
functions, is derivatives, and therefore the PDE
residues can be calculated exactly using automated
differentiation and a neural network prediction
that makes the PDE residue equal to zero is that
exactly satisfy The equation. So throughout the
training process, the neural network will
find an approximate representation of the
PDE solution by minimizing the loss function
that include both the PDE residue and the
associated boundary conditions. And I should
add that I think precinct four neural networks
are better for solving inverse problems, because
for forward problems, there are also many other
traditional solvers that are much faster than
pins. And in the next few slides, I will still
use forward problem as examples to just explain
how the multi stage pin works, but in the end,
I will talk about the impact of this approach
for A inverse problem. Okay, so before talking
about the detail, I want to emphasize again, the
importance of the scaling factor. So here is the
example of the Poissons equation. And this is nice
example, because we know the exact solution. So
here is the pin solution of the beneath pin to the
Poissons equation, and it has a prediction error
about 10 to the minus four because this solution
has high frequency features. I want to just remind
you that, due to the spectral bias, is harder for
pin to approximate a solution like this. But what
we can do again is to change this scaling factor.
So here, if we make the scaling factor that's
closer to the dominant frequency in this sourcing
term, six pi, now we can reduce the error by two
orders of magnitude just by changing this scaling
factor. Okay. So, okay. So how do we apply multi
stage idea to pins? We know that for the previous
regression data fitting problem, right, the
training data for the higher stage neural network
comes from the error of the previous stage and
that can be calculated if you know the if you know
the target function, if you know the ground truth.
But for solving PDS, we don't know the solution,
right? We don't we want to find the solution so
we do not know the target function. So in the case
when you don't have any target function, how do we
design the higher stage network? What would be the
training data? So. Okay, so now explain that in
the next few slides and using this simple example.
So here's a simple linear ODE, and again, the
residue is just the rewriting the equation here.
So this example also is quite nice. It has the
exact solution, and we will define the solution
error as the difference between your network
predictive solution with this exact solution.
Exact solution. Again, this gray colored text here
that's not going to be seen by the neural network
I'm showing here, just for validating our result.
Okay, so here is the pain result, pain prediction
compared to the exact solution and after the first
stage. So here is the PDE residue as a function of
input x. And here we did a we look at the residue
in a Fourier domain, so we can see its dominant
frequency. Interestingly, here we can calculate
the solution error by comparing the red and the
blue lines, and then here we this is the solution
error. We can also look at the solution error in
the frequency space. Again, this lower panel in
gray here is not seen by the algorithm I'm just
showing here for for your information. So one
thing interesting we see here is that the dominant
frequency of the PD residue is close to the
dominant frequency of the error of the solution.
Another thing is that the error of the solution,
the magnitude of the residue is larger compared to
the magnitude of the error of the solution. Okay,
so we know that to design a multi staging neural
network, we need to specify the order of magnitude
of the error for the second stage solution, which
is this epsilon one parameter. And the question
here is, how do we estimate this magnitude of
s1 with the absence of ground truth solution?
So here we can plug in this solution N sock into
the original PDE, and by doing so, we can obtain
a new PDE where the right hand side is simply the
PDU residue itself from the original equation. So
the first neural networks, PDE residue gives the
can gives the PDE for the second stage neural
network that solves for the highest stage term,
u1 and moreover, the magnitude of the dominant
term in the left hand side, in this case, is this
first derivative term. This term can be estimated
as the magnitude of u1 over X the X length scale
of u1 which is related to the dominant frequency
of u1 so if we want to balance in this equation,
the dominant terms are these two, highlighted in
blue by balancing these two dominant terms, we can
estimate that the magnitude of the solution error,
epsilon one based on the magnitude of the
equation residue and the frequency of the
PD residue. So we have all the information that we
need to estimate this epsilon one parameter. Okay,
and again, all this procedure can be automated.
So now you might ask, this is works for, you know,
OD with first derivative, how about higher
order derivatives? For higher order derivatives,
you can apply this very similar strategy. So here,
instead of estimating term that has u1 over x,
you will have like, one over x to the power of
n, where n is the number of derivatives in the
in this term. Okay, so a natural question is,
how about non linear equations? Right here is
we discussed that in our paper as well. Here is a
simple example where you have a u squared term in
your PDE. It turns out you have a question like
this. You can just follow the same procedure,
and then when you write down the second stage
PDE to train the second stage neural network,
you will see that because the epsilon one
parameter is much smaller than one. So all
these nonlinear terms that involve you one will
fall into a higher order, epsilon one square term,
and this can be generally disregarded. So this
suggests that although, despite the nonlinearity
of the original equation, the governing equation
for the higher stage network, essentially can
become a linear equation because this term is
negligible. Therefore the similar strategies
that I just described would apply here, and here
I'm just mentioning the basic intuitions of our
approach. I. If you want to see more details, you
can look at section 3.1, point two in our paper
for the four more derivations. Okay, so this is
just you to show the result. Here we have all we
need to conduct the multi stage training for pins.
We know that the frequency. So this is a the the
PD we're trying to solve. This is the first stage
PD residue, and this is the error of the first
stage PD solution. We know that the frequency
of the higher stage solution should be close
to the frequency of the residue. And using this
second equation, we can estimate the magnitude of
epsilon one, which is the magnitude of the highest
solution. So now we have all information needed
needed to optimize the second neural network.
And here we just showing that this works very
well. So the prediction from the second stage
neural network agrees very well with the expected
result. And again, the here, the error is not
provided as the training data, because we don't.
We don't the new network doesn't see the data
when training. The new network can only predict
the the solution because it's solving the PD for
the second stage your network so and here's your
show. After two stages, the multi stage solution
has an error that's close to 10 to the minus 13.
And after more stages, the solution can be
the error of a solution can approach 10 to
the power of 16, which is close to machine
precision of double floating points. Okay,
so this is just a quick summary previously for
regression problem. The training data for higher
stages come from the error of the previous stage,
and that can be calculated from the ground truth
target function for ping, the ground truth is
not available for calculating the error. However,
the PDE residue from the previous stage neural
network can be used to estimate the magnitude
and frequency of the higher stage PDE solution.
And the PDE of the higher stage neural network can
be written in terms of the PD residue of the
previous stage neural network. So we have all the
information we need from previous stage to train
the next stage and perform multi stage training
for this important for the physical network.
Again, all these procedure can be automated. Okay,
so this is just to show the scaling of the error.
Here you can even enhance the algorithm by adding
the gradient of the residue in the loss function
term. It's also called GPMs. So here, if you look
at the throughout subsequent stages, the error of
the solution compared to the dominant frequency
of the error, you can see it also follows a
power law for regression problem we solve the
power has like one over six exponent here, with
the addition of PD loss in the cost function,
we have a steeper slope, so it's about close
to one over eight. Okay, so that was for ping
with 1d with ODE. And here is a simple PDE
example, right? So here we have a diffusion,
diffusion equation like this, where we also have
the have an analytical solution. And here you can
see the first stage ping error is about 10 to
the power of minus four. After three stages on,
the error can be pushed down to 10 to the minus
nine, and this is just to show the same scaling
law of the error of the solution versus the
dominant frequency of the errors. Okay, so this
is the introduction of how this multi stage, high
precision neural network work. And so what can is,
you know, all the example I showed so far are
the example where we already have analytical
solutions. So in practice, what can we use this
high precision neural network for? And here, I
want to show example where it can be used to solve
some very challenging PDE so it can actually be
used to find some PDE solutions that are otherwise
quite difficult to find with classical methods as
an example. So I'll talk about the Navier Stokes
equation. Navier stokes equation is widely used in
various applications in science and engineering,
right for two, more than two centuries. It's also
my favorite equations in the world because
of. Because of its universality. However,
there are also many unsolved questions concerning
the fundamental behavior of the Navier Stokes
equation. In particular, we do not know if the
Navier Stokes equation always exists, a solution
that always exists, a solution for any smooth,
bound initial condition. So one of the pathway
to tackle this problem is to find a solution to
the Navier Stokes equation that can blow up at
finite time. If I can find this example, that will
be a counter example of the statement that navier
stokes equation always is a unique and smooth
solution at any times. So here we want to see if
our high precision multi station neural network
can be used to find blowout solutions. And this
question, this open question, are also very
important for not only for Navier Stokes,
but also the Euler equation. Let's go back. So for
Euler equation, this will be the focus of the next
few slides, and this work was also recently
published in Physical Review Letters. Okay,
so this is the Euler equation. It's simply the
Navier Stokes equation with zero viscosity. A open
question for this equation that remains unsolved
for over a century is whether smooth and finite
energy initial condition can blow up in finite
time. In the past decades, there has been several
progress made by direct numerical simulations, and
that suggests singularity formation for the Euler
equation. However, you can imagine that near the
time of blowing up, near the time of singularity,
the time and space resolution needed to
resolve the dynamics are extremely high,
so we need really, really fine resolution to
resolve the singularity. The smallest length
scale and the largest scale can spend over
more than 12 orders of magnitude. So this is
this post and multi scale numerical challenge
to this problem, and in the next few slides,
I will show how we can tackle this problem
with a multi stage visiting formula network.
So we first reduce the dimensionality, so
we are working in a self similar domain,
and here we use a visiting formula network
to approximate four parameters we want to
solve for as a function of two self similar input
coordinate. So throughout the training iterations,
the algorithm will search for the four solution
profiles that satisfy the self similar eulers
equation. And I want to emphasize that this is
not a this is not a forward problem, because in
this set of equation, we have a critical unknown
parameter. We have a non parameter in the set of
equations. So the search for the solution along
with this unknown parameter is an inverse problem
instead of a forward problem. And I will skip
a lot of numerical details here. These are
documented in the supplementary material of our
paper, but our neural network can see that is
again, so this is a loss versus iteration and the
convergence of the neural network approximation of
the solution over iterations, so our new network
can numerically found. Can you numerically find a
set of approximate, smooth, self similar solutions
that exhibit singularities to the eulers equation,
and this is one of the example where neural
network has found PD solutions that had not been
found before with other more classical methods,
here you can calculate the accuracy of a solution
by substitute the neural network of solution
into the PDE and look at the PD residues. So
this quantum, quantum magazine article, this, they
did a good job explaining the background of this
problem and our progress. And Charles Fefferman,
he's not directly involved in this work. He's
the author of the statement of existence and
smoothness of the Navier Stokes equation. So
he mentioned in the quantum article that our
result is is quantitative and is precise and
has a good chance of being made rigorous. So
this is very exciting to us, because this is a
possible strategy to tackle various block problem
where the classical simulation is difficult. Okay,
so just want to sum up by saying that. There has
been several challenges in this general area of
high precision learning, and there are also a
lot of progress that's been made. So in front
different angles, for example, there's many, many
work that focus on how to enhance the function
approximation error. And there are so paper that
tackles how to do faster optimization, like second
order optimization methods. I think Marius is
actually giving a talk in this seminar series
next week. Look forward to that. And there's also
how to approximate high frequency functions. We
already mentioned this paper previously for in the
context of pin, there's various work that discuss
how to determine how to weight different terms
in the loss function, and the overall goal here
is to make the convergence rate in for different
terms in the loss function roughly comparable.
And there's also some work focused on how to
have a strategy that optimize the sampling
of COVID condition point, and how do you
choose optimal activation functions of
neural network? Finally, there are also
work by Misra that look at, in addition,
whether we can say something about the error
bound of the solution based on the PD residue.
Okay, so I'll encourage you to check out all these
papers and to sum up this talk, which that multi
stationary network can boost approximation
accuracy, it can tackle spectral bias and
enhance the neural network precision to machine
precision. It doesn't it takes less computational
cost in a single unit. And this is useful for
representation, representation and representing
flow that exhibit multi scale features. We have
also applied to find blue solutions to Euler,
and this is a challenging multi scale problem in
the future, we're interested in systematic study
of the use of these for various types of PDs, and
we also want to see if we can use this to improve
surrogate models. So how can this, you know, very
precise neural network you can be How can you be
used to help to mitigate error and instabilities
in the machine learning based emulators. And yeah.
So finally, I want to thank my wonderful group
members. Young Juan is really the core developer
of the deep learning algorithm. None of the
result would be possible without without him and
Jenkin and Charles are my students who contributed
substantially to the deep learning algorithms our
code. So many people ask me about the code, and
it is open source, available. If you want to try,
can go to this link, and I'll be very happy to
answer any questions. Thank you to stop here.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful
talk Yao that was very informal, and I'm sure
everyone here on the lab, okay, let's have a Q and
A session. Say, I don't see any questions in the
chat room, so if you have questions, please unmute
yourself. Ask questions. Don't be shy. Oh yes,
Lucas, just ask the questions. Is that?
Thanks a lot for the presentation. It
was very clear and informative. Where can we
find the slides of the presentations? Okay,
we are going to make this video like the
recorded video available in the YouTube.
You can check it there or Yao, do you
mind share your slides to audience? Yeah.
What would be the best way to do that?
You can forward that to me, and then, you know,
yeah, I can, yeah. I'll forward
to the slides. No problem. Yeah.
All right, thank you for the question.
Lucas Jerome, thank you for the
presentation. I was just struck a little bit by
the fact that there's a relationship it seems,
between doing the the second level neural network
and maybe the norm that you're using for the
error, right? If you maybe used for the PD, it's
natural to use like the h1 norm so it can include,
like the gradients in the error. So I was just
wondering if you had some thoughts on that.
So I couldn't hear exactly every
word. Let me try that again.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, there's technical.
Oh, yeah. So I was just thinking that there's
a relationship between what you're doing and,
like, the choice of the norm you use
for measuring the error. And, like,
in the PBE case, at least it's would be natural
to use, like, the h1 norm. So you would include
the gradients, you know, the difference in
the gradients and the in the error, which
would naturally tend to grab a lot more of the
high frequency terms. So I just wondered if you,
if you had thought about that, and you know, there
was a relationship there that you had explored.
Yeah, you're talking about how how
to report errors, right? And yeah,
because that that how you
decide on the error, like,
determines how the thing is, is trained, right?
The error the training is using l2 actually,
sometimes we use LP and the pre, yeah, our way
of that is a good question. Yeah, we can use,
if you used L, you know, the h1 norm,
which is like, just like, you know,
the square of that error, plus the square of
the error and the gradients, then it would
naturally, which is not, which is the natural one
that we use for like, PDS, for like, second order,
PDS would would tend to capture a lot of the error
that just using the l2 norm would miss, right?
I think this is a good, good, good, good
suggestion. Yeah, we couldn't definitely,
we, you know, we can definitely help
calculate H on error without problem,
yeah, so, yeah, I will be curious to see
there's a, what I'm trying to say, is
there a relationship between doing that
sort of second level of neural
networks, and including, say,
higher order terms in the error metric. But
both of them are attempting to train towards,
you know, something that captures
high, higher frequency terms, more.
Yeah, that's a good that's a good suggestion
we have not really as calculate, you know,
Edge one error so far is still ongoing work,
and we're just really looking at a simple
difference between but, yeah, I see what you
I see your point. English is a good thing to
to do. We can definitely yeah, report, yeah.
Thank you, Robert. I know you put
the question in the chat room,
but do you want to unmute yourself and then ask?
Yeah, sure. So you mentioned
at the start of your talk,
maybe when you talk after you wanting to
investigate why you're seeing that alpha
coefficient appearing over and over again
with your graphs. Have you looked into any
of the research on the empirical
scaling laws for neural networks?
Yeah, yeah. So the empirical, the empirical,
deep scaling convergence laws, and that's yeah,
what can you remember? What's
the alpha value on there?
So interestingly, the alpha values there seem to
work something like a condition number, an analog
for like mathematical problems, in that they are
constant for the problem being discussed, but are
independent of the network architecture used, but
only sometimes. There's like research that shows
that LSTMs and transformers, for example, have
a four fold difference in their coefficients.
Interesting? Yeah, I think, Oh, here. I think
there's a there. Yeah, this is something
I'm really curious to see, because in our case,
it's especially quite consistent with what we see,
that the independence of the architecture and
the depth and width, but so I've been looking
at it for a while. It's like, you know,
we can talk afterwards, but basically,
the the other questions I had, I just wanted
to kind of alert you into that, because I think
there's a connection to what you're doing there.
And I also, like, wanted to ask, Do you have any
insights about how the size of the network affects
the frequency response of your networks? If I take
my if I say, add 1000 times more parameters to
my network, can it capture more spectral modes?
I really like this question because I had that
exact same question, like, a year ago, you know,
like, if we draw now due to Fourier series,
right? You would think that more terms you will
be able to capture, like, a wide, broader range
of frequencies. Interestingly, if we let's do a
simple test and. Simple thought process, thought
experiment, if we just have one single hidden
layer and then replace all the activation function
by sign signs. So it's like close to like a
Fourier series. And then you ask the question, Can
increasing number of neurons increase the ability
for a neural network to capture higher frequency
data, the answer is actually no, because that
depends on how you initialize the neural network,
and the ultimate optimization procedure is really
the architecture itself is fine, but is the way
neural network learn how to optimize parameters.
That's like limiting its represent representation
accuracy. So that's why, that's why, in our in our
case, we initially, we just increased the depth
and width. And that has, like, I think you will
also see a scaling law actually, right? But
the exponent is not as large as six. Yeah.
The scalings are usually really, really poor,
like, I wonder. And the session brings into the
reason I asked the third question there is, how
do you apply this idea to a problem where you
can't really do a frequency analysis, like, say, I
wanted to take and do a multi stage neural network
for something like an LLM, how could I do
that without being able to analyze the Kappa?
I see that's a very good question. So if
you think, I think what the llms are seeing are
basically the same phenomena that you are seeing
on these physics problems, right? They have
some problem. And you read the studies on how
they suddenly, things suddenly grok like it really
sounds to me, for someone who has a physics basis,
as in, they've suddenly discovered a frequency
mode of the underlying data. And you look at these
networks a lot like they usually smooth over noise
until they suddenly find a signal in the noise,
which could be like, analogous to suddenly
finding the frequency and a feature space where
this all suddenly makes sense, but it'd be really
interesting. And we have lots of problems around
here where I'd love to apply a techno like this.
I've spent, like, you know, two years trying to
fit a network to machine precision or something,
and failing. And like, no one has been able to,
like, find a network that can make it like,
written down. So I'm really excited by this, but
we have problems where you can't do a frequency
analysis to find what the dominant frequency
is. I'm, yeah, I'm very interested in and
intrigued by your question. So in the LFM,
then the question is, what's the what does it
mean when a new network is of low precision? Yeah,
right. Like, is it also fitting? Some like, what
does it mean that? What's the part that's it's
not fitting? Yeah, I don't know the answer.
I'm just curious. Yeah, so we can talk more.
All right, thank you for the question
and answer. That's wonderful. Any other
questions from audience? I think William, you
raised a hand one time and still there. Yeah,
I guess it was kind of somewhat related to
what you were talking about. I was curious if,
when you're implementing it, if you needed to
go through and, like, tune each auto encoder
architecture as you're going through and adding
these extra levels. But it sounds like if you just
feed in the data, it doesn't architecture
doesn't matter if you feed in the errors,
the actual architecture doesn't matter that
much. It's just what you're training on,
exactly like the there's no the only thing that
we have to decide because all the parameters,
like the scaling factor that tune the the weight
of the neural network of the higher stage neural
network. Those can be determined just from the
result of previous stage. So those are not,
not really the tuning parameter, but
one thing we do have to decide is,
is one to stop the training of a particular stage
so that is still, we kind of decide manually,
you really good to have a way to automate
that process. I don't know if that answer,
yeah, yeah, definitely. Thank you.
I have one questions for the multi
stage pins. You have to provide some
Co Location points as well. Do you see?
You know your multi stage pins convergence
behavior depending on the number of
CO locations and position location
of the CO location points as well? Have
you probably you have done some studies.
This is actually a very important question.
So if we actually for the ping case, we have
done something almost similar to the regression
problem. The first thing we try is increasing the
collocation point, and we see that error doesn't
really come like an error goes. Down, but there's
a limit of the error of this, of the PDE solution.
So then we know, then, then that's when we know
the limitation of the error is no longer coming
from colocation points. Is the architect. It's
the optimization of the network. It's like
not learning these high frequency features.
So then when we add the second stage network, we
have to still do the same experiment. We have to
see make sure we have enough collocation point so
it's not limited. The accuracy is not limited by
the number of collision point. It's limited
by the optimization of the weight and bias.
Also, you're not using the same Co
Location point set from the previous
days. You always go back and then try to
find out, you know, what is the enough?
They don't have to be the same.
They don't have to be the same. But
I think it's easier if we just use the
highest density of points. Let me like
the regression problem. The cop, the downside
is, is that you increase the computational time
if you just use highest possible closure
and point density in the beginning. So
in the beginning you can use less. In the
higher stage, you need to use more points.
Right? Right?
I think problem is really not
it's really too expensive to
do this. It's really for this special type of PD,
you really need high precision and an inverse
problem where deriving a joint for this couple
of individuals is challenging. That's the type
of problem where I see it's beneficial, right?
Right? I'm just curious. You know,
the pins usually takes a long time to,
you know, get the converts to solutions. How about
your multi stage pins? Any benefit
of accelerating that training at all?
So depend on what you meant by accelerate.
If you ask the for the same precision,
what's the computational time compared to the
regular pin? The answer is yes, it's faster,
right? Yeah.
But like,
if you compare that with a
traditional PD, is over, then
there is definitely not. Like, I don't,
I wouldn't recommend using this to solve
for normal like diffusion equation. That
was like, we're showing how this work,
like a simple example where you
have analytical solution, right?
Alright, thank you. The robot you
seems to have on other questions.
I have like, 18 questions. So that's fine.
That's one more. Okay.
Well, so like the the last question I have
there is, what happens? Have you ever had the
network predict the Kappa figure for
you during training of the residual?
I think it is kind of being
predicted by the neural network,
because the Kappa is determined from the
outcome of the previous stage, usually.
So if the network could predict the Kappa,
like if I'm if I'm training the residual,
the first residual network and then second
residual, if they're each picking their own Kappa,
that would offer a way for you to apply
this to problems where there isn't a clear
four year analysis analog, because in those
situations you can't calculate that explicitly,
but if the network could find it during its
own training, that would be given mechanism
for this to have way more generalizability
to a whole host of different problems.
I see that's a really, really good point. It
can, I think so this depends on, I think it's
related to the question of the scaling law,
because the scaling law actually gives you,
you can track down the scaling law and then
find out what's the cop out for the error. So,
yes, if you know the error of the first network,
you can kind of estimate the kata. Yeah, that's,
that's, that's a really good point.
Like, such a cool idea. Okay, yeah,
but I still don't, you know. I
don't know how universe, like,
we question I'm really interested in is,
how, why is there scaling law for this?
Like, why is it one over six? Like, we have
empirically showing like, is it universal? Like,
how universal is it? When does it break down?
Right? This kind of question I'm very interested
in. I'm extremely interested in this. Well,
it's this, the empirical scaling laws,
and the fact that these coefficients keep
appearing over and over again is driving me
crazy. And I'm glad that at least someone with
a mathematical background is looking at it.
I'd love to chat more. Yeah, touch.
I mean, my follow on questions to that those
discussions between you would be even though,
even though you know those kappa value can be
induced from the previous training by looking at
the. Visual, you know, dynamics, and therefore we
can apply that to the problems where the four year
analysis is not available, but still, LLM, I don't
see. How is it? It is applicable to there? Well,
so it's, there's, there's, there's research
that shows that they can do like mathematical
analysis backing out stuff in llms, and they can
show that at least English seems to work on a 42
dimensional manifold that we don't understand.
But they can do like analysis of convergent laws
and various stuff to show that, hey, like, there
is like a 42 dimensional space that thought seems
to occur in, and with doing vector operations
in that space, you can do stuff too. So, like,
we can't understand it, but there
is a high dimensional space where,
like an FF team should apply. We don't know what
it is, and the networks can't approximate it well,
but like, all these ideas should apply to those
spaces as well. Like, I think that some, again,
I wrote it in the chat. Like, I've tried for
a while to get networks to do a reversion,
a convergence thing, like you're describing,
and I've never been able to get it to work,
just kind of on the side while I'm doing other
things. I really think the frequency analysis
is very, very key to finally getting like a
spectral and multi scale type thing working
here. I think that is the key. Thing is you've
added something to the network that allows you
to capture different modes explicitly, and that is
what is making the whole process work. And that's
what give is giving you convergence factors of
scaling factors that are factors of 10 bigger
than anything else I've seen when I'm looking
at conversion stuff elsewhere in literature.
Well, I mean, that's a cool idea of, you know,
those English for example, it can be embedded
into the 42 dimensional vector space, but I
still don't see how that is can be used to,
you know, provide some residual
information. So unless there is
some sort of governing equations to, you
know, guide those residuals, yeah, of
course. Well, the first example did like
they showed, example in the beginning,
where you get able to do it without having the
governing rituals, residual equations. You can
just look at the residuals for the problem, and
we have those for things like L stands. So I mean,
we have those for every problem, so there's a
general result from the thing. So even though
we don't have the governing equations, the data,
actual data, can still apply it directly from the
data, right? Okay, cool. Any other questions?
It's past the time. Unfortunately, I'm sure many
exciting questions will come up, but we have
to wrap up soon, so maybe one more questions
we can take. Well, if not, let's thank our
speaker, Yao, for the wonderful talk and
wonderful Q and A sessions. And I'm sure that many
people is going to be interested in your work,
Yao and future collaborations hopefully comes
out, you know, initiated by this seminar.
Yeah. Thank you. Lin, thank you, yeah,
Robert, for the points about LLM. I'm very
interested. I need to learn more about it. So,
awesome, awesome. Okay, all right. Well, thank
you. Yeah. With that, we conclude the talk, yes.
Thank you. See you. Bye.